Okay, well, we always love the way
that you tell it like it is,
so we came up with a little game
that we're hoping you'll play with us
called state of the union.
Oh, oh yes. (crowd claps)
I feel like I might be okay at this, all right.
All right, we're gonna ask you a few questions.
Give us your opinion.
It's state of the union.
(inspiring music) (crowd claps)
Okay, on a scale of one to 10,
how hurt were your feelings
when Kaavia said that your breath stunk
in this recent viral video.
Roll the tape so we can see what we're talking about here.
(Kaavia blowing out breath)
Are you, is that 'cause my breath stinks?
Yeah.
(man laughing evilly)
Kaavia, what should I do if I think my breath stinks.
Say. (blows out)
See, I love that.
That's exactly what you're talking about.
Just keep it real.
(crowd claps)
That would be a 10.
I was like, oh.
I love you, okay.
Earlier in the Drew's News we discussed the Tinder Swindler.
Have you ever been swindled by a date?
I would call that my first marriage.
(all laugh)
(crowd claps)
I am so in love with you, it hurts.
This is why I love you.
God, just God.
Okay. The internet debate of 2022 is,
are there more doors or wheels in the world?
I hadn't heard about this
but apparently it's a huge internet debate.
Which one would you guess?
I would probably go with wheels
'cause there's so many cars.
Yeah.
I think the answer is that's really, probably
one of the tamest debates going on on our planet right now.
What is your take on the new spring 2022 trend?
Now this is a fashion trend.
Every single runway show
just had full blown mini skirt action everywhere.
Now you rock the mini skirt better than anybody.
What do you think of the mini skirt trend, in or out?
Oh, in, in, in, in, much to the older kids dismay.
They're like, "Can you please put some clothes on?"
And I'm like, "No."
As long as these things are sitting where they're sitting
and gravity hasn't completely taken hold, yeah.
You really take good care of yourself, you show us all.
You wear that mini skirt, you earned it.
(crowd claps)
I was just eating spicy Appetito pickles
and having a cocktail.
So I don't know if I'm exactly
always taking care of myself,
but I'm gonna still wear the skirt.
Listen, they say the key to life is balance
and anyone who keeps it too straight
is not my cup of tea, all right.
And I want people who, you know,
take care of people and don't judge each other
and you are all of the things
that I hold sacrosanct in this world. (crowd claps)
Gabriel Union, I love you so much.
Thank you so much for coming on this show.
You drink that wine, you do you.
We love you.
"Cheaper by the Dozen" is available now on Disney Plus.
It's such a fun movie, get it while it's hot.
(upbeat theme music)